[Music]
we had what was basically a hometown
date and so much sexuality are you ready
for round five round five this is your
bachelor season 24 episode 1 recap it's
time for roses and Rose Bay hi everybody
it's me Lauren Zima and we are back
where we belong oh it's been a while I
hope you guys were watching our sip or
spill interview game episodes with
bachelor nation alumni but now we are
here to find some new alumni aka a whole
new cast of characters with the new
bachelor Peter Webber the man in the
cockpit
Wow I'm so happy to be back with you
again on the run scripts driving me
crazy
these shoulder pads are so annoying
you guys I bought this shirt because I
thought oh let's go big do you get it
but I it feels like it's made of tissue
paper because I mean of aluminum foil
like it's made of that kind of plastic a
tablecloth that you get at a party city
I don't like it Otto and this couch
won't stop farting we're gonna get a new
set okay it's happening we're talking
about it at the end of the video bottom
line though this is Peter Webber's
premiere let's get to it
what did everyone think of the premiere
I loved it I adored it I thought it was
sexual I thought it was dark I thought
it was fabulous okay there's something I
just found out all of us just found out
but before the premiere even dust begun
we get a preview of what to expect on
this season some kind of shocker what
will they tell Peter what will make
Peter Piper's mother cry oh my god I
don't like it she's so sweet I love
Peter Weber's parents you guys Chris
welcome home so let's get to the episode
first of all Oh
I haven't poured my so many wine yet am
i all right
this shirt is throwing me off shoulder
pads I can't reach for my wine properly
it's the premier don't drink every time
they make a plain mention don't drink
every time they make an aviation pun
let's just forget of all this maybe well
expect some turbulence along the way I
met the controls and I just gotta find
that copilot welcome aboard
do not drink every time Hannah Brown is
mentioned I never expected to feel the
way I felt even though I was in love
with him and don't drink every time we
talk about windmills
football and chen jeiza hi you ready for
round five yeah it all happened a lot in
the premiere what did you think were you
enjoyed or were you annoyed let me know
in the comments below
hi I'm Alexa I'm 27 I'm a caregiver so
of course we get our beautiful intro
packages everyone my name is Tina Ann
and welcome to Knoxville to see Hannah
Anne is from Knoxville and she is a
model but she's so normal everybody I'm
just a normal girl I love her she said
she was a model but she wants to
reassure everyone she's normal like no
one thought you weren't but she is
gorgeous she's beautiful the only thing
she has going against her is that her
name is Hannah Hannah and Hannah and I
love that name right perhaps but
triggering for Peter we'll see then we
have Tammy from Syracuse she's a fighter
fighter since I was a kid and a house
flipper she flipped houses as well and
Tammy is right I love that she said that
she's not afraid she's not afraid to
move a piece of furniture rearranged
rooms if I need to she's not afraid to
paint a wall and I'm not afraid of that
I think what's that so I'd say I had to
grow up pretty pretty fast pretty young
and we had some women with beautiful
stories and then finally I just woke up
one day like it's time to get yourself
together Marissa let's go and oh my god
I mean they were already crying I was
already having tears myself it was
beautiful all my love to you ladies I'm
Kelly I'm 27 years old Kelly is an
attorney and she met Peter by chance at
a hotel before filming even began it's
hard not to look at that situation and
think that wasn't a major sign oh wow is
that legal in the bachelor world Kelly
it is it's fine it's reality TV everyone
always acts like there are rules but
they're not you guys that's what we do
get the drama
Madison Pruitt is from Auburn Alabama
Auburn Alabama another Auburn woman
drink every time that you just got a
Hannah Brown vibe beforehand around even
showed up
is pulling in right now let the journey
begin then we get the limo arrivals and
some shade Oh Sydney also from Alabama
told him and I quote not every girl from
Alabama every girl from gamma makes that
decision makes bad decisions draws the
[ __ ]
Sydney oh me oh my with the shade so
dark I figured since I'm a flight
attendant and you're no way drink every
time we have a flight attendant in the
house so on the flight attendant boo
ladies and gentlemen welcome aboard
flight 143 with Jack service to Peter's
heart
apparently everyone and their mother is
a flight attendant and I also want to
cheers to Peter because with each one of
these flight attendants he gave a
reaction as though they were the first
he was like oh my god paper airplane
okay drink every time you the paper
airplane Wow
[Music]
didn't even freaking fly we had to
Google how to fold that it's been a
while hmm what would you guys as
entrances with Peter Webber have been
let me know in the comments below I
think I would have brought in a tiny
tray of airplane food I like eating on
planes it's as simple anyway don't drink
the entire time it took Cortney that
cosmetologist to make her way up to the
mansion
she was peddling on some kind of a shark
plane I think they cut out a lot of it
it looks like a real struggle for
Cortney and I want to applaud her for
the effort but it felt quite sad didn't
it okay I'm going for the mile-high club
you know we're making the plane puns
we're joking about aviation I've made it
to my final destination we've got a lot
of references but then someone asked
what I thought to be a very powerful
question we don't know who it was we
only heard the audio but this woman said
it's like are you a co-pilot are you
guys are you a copilot or are you
baggage Oh i sat right back I said Wow
let me think about that and there's so
much you can say you know are you smooth
sailing or are you turbulence are you
first-class or an exit row that's like
some David Copperfield what and then we
get everybody covenant with the great
lines like this Victoria gal we've got a
couple of Victoria's well Victoria F
made a joke about being dry or wet very
dry sense of humor
I liked the interaction of Kellie and
Peter and she was a strong character on
this episode revealing her and Peter had
met briefly by chance before filming
even began but then oh oh oh one woman
in particular has arrived that's the
front door didn't even though we knew
her appearance will be coming we'd seen
it in promos we were aware that it would
be happening it still felt quite
striking didn't it
[Music]
Hannah Brown everybody Anna hey yes
Hannah Brown appeared at the mansion
um it's not especially confusing
interaction and she comes back later in
the episode I think to help explain the
baffling moment where she gave Peter
back his wings brought these back for
you because he's got a flight now right
I gotta fly in his own really difficult
to fly with these shoulder pads in I
don't know how I'd love it do it in the
eighties someone says is that legal I
don't know ask Kelly the lawyer and you
know what
don't drink for all the fur so much wine
left don't drink for all the weird puns
they were made about Peter being a dime
like dime fifty being a biscuit and he
looks like you're really biscuit someone
said you gotta risk it for the biscuit
you need to risk it for the biscuit what
I don't know what it means but I loved
it and I was just sitting there thinking
how I got apply that to myself I'm like
you got a shine for the wine you got to
be a champ for the shams
you got a kill for the tequila is it too
much take off and then Peter was doing
some paper plane stuffed with Madison
and they seem to have a connection he
kept telling her that he was so glad she
was here I'm bad at all things with
sports you know don't give me anything
you need thrown what did you think of
Madison I felt they had a strong bond
early on one of the greatest gifts you
can give your children is showing them
what a healthy marriage is Hannah and
does seem real sweet the normal model
from Tennessee she gave Peter this
painting which was borderline weird but
not I thought it was cute let me know in
the comments below how you felt about it
I did think it was telling that Peter
kept saying her name over and over again
Hannah Hannah Hannah Hannah and Hannah
and Hannah Ann that means he was
noticing her
how did we feel about Hannah and she had
already spoken to Peter they'd had a
wonderful time together and she kept
barging in I felt it was unnecessary
Anna Anna had a great moment with him
and now you're just gonna make the other
women a night of fear right let me know
in the comments below I want to talk to
him now I'm going next [ __ ] actually
wild on night one night one guess in
everybody's heads you know I'm saying
I'm not gonna judge to heart at night
one you're up all night
you're drinking just a normal Wednesday
anyway I also disagreed with Hannah when
she said and I quote I'm not here to sit
on a couch and drink wine I'm not here
to sit on a couch and drink wine Hannah
Anna were very different you broaden
your horizons your way and ILA broaden
my horizon
[Laughter]
it really urge me to find out that was
her third time hey Jenna can I talk to
you for a second yeah oh my god a full
circle a full flight path of drama we
have gone from sealing time to already
confronting Hannah Ann about sealing
time I don't even know this woman's name
and she's like I really think it wasn't
appropriate that you spoke when I was
trying to speak to Peter but like I want
to be able to like speak my mind and
have my time with him as well yeah and
and I want that for you too this season
is off to a start am i right
hi Peter hello now this Victoria F comes
back he's a little nervous she speaks to
Peter and she wants to discuss with
Peter that dry/wet joke that she made
the dryer thing oh that's right yes and
Peter doesn't even remember it
repeat what you say again I'm so sorry
she's crying and breaking down because
she made this incredibly dirty
borderline inappropriate for television
comment and Peter Webber that sweet boy
he didn't remember her dirty joke Peter
Webber don't remember her humor was dry
but not dry enough anyway okay
miss Hanahan will you accept this rose
yes yes and after night one Hannah and
gets the first impression rose were you
surprised
I kind of was they had such a good
conversation but I thought after oliver
interrupting peter might say well i'm
gonna go to somebody else doesn't it
interesting under Neves hannah that's
difficult that's a lot to process right
it just made me question a lot of things
i put myself out there for a second I
wrote down some woman is crying about
not getting the rose but idk who she is
we don't I won't know them for three
more weeks Victoria P and then the rose
ceremony is happening and goodbye
Marissa left she was cute eh I didn't
see this coming at all
moving on because this is a three hour
premiere so just makes you feel so alive
here we go the first group date and of
course
Laura Plains stuff so they're on the
first group date and they have to go to
flight school and they have to do math
oh yeah
fill my three-times then cut yourself oh
I wrote down goodbye good night I'm done
math plus me equals by e-card
gyroscope hopefully they go in this
spinny thing and a different woman named
Victoria says and I quote we have to
spin on the spinny thing I'm freaking
out cuz I get motion sickness easy and
drink every time she talks about puking
the last time I wrote on the little
teacup spinny thing I vomited but I've
never done up in front of a boy before
cuz I get motion sickness Katie it was
analyse again right the childhood trauma
then they're doing its obstacle course
and the prize is actually good a song
set play with Peter Webber it's
borderline sailing but I thought the
obstacle course was funny what did you
guys think drink every time someone fell
down during that wind thing our girl
Kelly the legal eagle
allegedly cheats and wins and gets to
fly did you think Kelly played fair let
me know in the comments below or should
she be disbarred Madison so much
happened in this first episode then we
get the first one-on-one date with
Madison we also got so much sexuality
this episode already right here was
making out with Kelly knee put her up on
that counter and we know Peter loves
poor people apart things like when he
put Hannah up on that pool table well
now he's putting Kelly up on a counter
by the way shameless blog I asked Peter
if he had already become a member of or
would be joining the mile-high club on a
season of The Bachelor you can check out
those in a reasonably ETL ENCOM way
except this Chris
[Music]
and Kelly got the rose
were you surprised they seems to have a
real connection but of course people
were upset because Kelly met Peter
beforehand I didn't think that was fair
for them to be mad at her it seemed to
be by all accounts a chance meeting we
can't hold that against her it's not as
though they dated before am i right let
me know in the comments below
okay I'm going on then we got a
one-on-one with mattis son and oh my god
hon this was basically a hometown date
am i right
Peter's adorable parents who have
graciously in real life loud to adopt me
thank you both renew their vows and it
was so beautiful they are so wonderful
tell me what you thought but Madison was
a part of that so she literally on the
very first one-on-one date of the season
that Peters whole family wild I largely
think this was about logistics we've
never had a lead who was born and grew
up and lived five minutes from the
mansion Peters from Westlake Village
California he literally told me he used
to go and like try to sneak into the
mansion as a kid yeah shameless plug
check it out a TTL Endeca all right one
more group date in the longest premiere
in the history of the show and Hannah
Brown is back in town again I ran out of
paper so I had to take the rest of these
notes on my phone so the group date is
that all of the women have to share a
story about
you all are going to share a personal
story about sex it was really weird
seeing Hannah up on stage like that with
Peter we don't get to any of the women's
sex stories we are just focused on the
odyssey of Peter
aunt Anna please tell me what you guys
thought about this interaction between
the two of them I frankly was blown away
we had seen in the teasers that Hannah
would be back to talk to Peter but this
conversation was more real and raw than
I had imagined nor predicted right drink
every time a complete bombshell was
dropped a question Hannah says she
questions her decision a question a lot
Peter says he's not where he thought he
was I don't know what to do it right now
I'm so confused
Hannah talks about Tyler Cameron well he
was like reaching out and like you
didn't say anything I didn't know where
you were I know if you just wanted to
get past it I wanted to be the bash
limey I thought you wanted to be a
bachelor so she thought Peter just
wanted to be the bachelor huh it was
bombshell after bombshell oh yeah and
then Peter asks Hannah if she will join
his season what would you say if I asked
you to
a part of the house maybe I don't think
that happens because I was interviewing
Hannah Brown regularly every week for
Dancing with the Stars I'm just not sure
logistical ëhow she would have had the
time to film both shows but did you feel
that was a fair ask is it fair to Hannah
is it fair to the women is it fair to
Peter himself their chemistry still felt
so real and so pained and the question I
really wanted Hannah to answer that she
didn't in what we saw was why did she
choose Tyler instead of Peter at the end
there because she kept telling Peter she
thought it would be him and chat in the
end I don't know either way she picked
Jeff so you know that happened anyway
this blue-ish up do you feel that Hannah
and Peter should still be together who
did you think Peter had the strongest
connection with after the premiere and
perhaps most importantly do you know how
to fold a paper plate I love you guys so
much we will be here every Tuesday with
a new episode of roses at Rose day
recapping this season of The Bachelor
you can find me on cameo if you want a
personal message from me and as always
feel free to reach out tell me your
questions thoughts concerns I do have to
make an important announcement as much
as I love this great couch and
everything we've been through sometimes
you have to break up and move on to a
new relationship so we will be getting a
new set as of next week
yes 2020 new year we've gotta move
forward and we're gonna pour one out for
the old set as we should we would never
waste good rose' everybody this is Chris
and Christine's a producer who's joining
our roses and Rose a team she's gonna be
here with me and JC every week making
wonderful content for you
cheers babe by E
[Music]